chuckling retailers hope to see a
holiday boost this weekend 71% of
Americans plan the shop today in stores
and online according to a National
Retail Federation survey another study
found the average household will spend
more than 15-hundred dollars over the
holidays that is more than 25 percent
higher than last year
CBS News financial contributor Mellody
Hobson is joining us now from San
Francisco melody good morning good
morning
so listen holiday sales start so early
these days that I wonder if it should be
called Black November instead of Black
Friday is it still as critical for
retailers on this specific day I'm going
to quote that Mark Twain quote
paraphrase it the tales of the demise of
brick-and-mortar retailers he has been
greatly exaggerated this is the Super
Bowl of shopping today more than one in
three Americans will go in a store today
and the conditions are ripe for
retailers as was mentioned unemployment
at 50 years lows wages are up consumer
confidence is really high Thanksgiving
an extra week early so you get seven
extra days of shopping
not to mention across the country the
weather is even good so if they can't
make it work now this is a no excuses
environment it should be good for
retailers so melody brick-and-mortar is
not dead purr Mark Twain's quote
slightly amended but 44% of these
shoppers are gonna be making their
purchases on mobile phones how is that
changing the way stores do business yes
so it's a big deal this really matters
the phone they recognize that a lot of
mobile apps have been upgraded and
changed in order to make them more
frictionless and user-friendly for the
customer so you stores like Walmart for
example that have mobile maps of their
stores that allow you to locate the
items before you get there pretty smart
you have Macy's that has mobile checkout
they recognize you might be in the store
shopping with your phone check out the
item go past all of the lines etc just
go to a mobile checkout counter show
your ID and get your item and walk out
the store so they recognize the phone is
a part of the purchase even if you're in
the store
not to mention like Vlad you might be
checking the price to make sure you're
getting the best price unless it's an
exclusive item they're often going to
match the best price that you see online
in order to get the sale I guess in the
end melody everybody just wants the good
deal so how do you make sure that you're
actually getting a good deal that's a
great question because at the end of the
day it's the price you pay
not the discount I think that's the
mistake that people make many retailers
start at a different list price and so
you want to make sure it at the end of
the day you realize what are you paying
not did I get 50% off or 60% off the
bottom line price and again you can
comparative shop so easily these days
you can see that number holiday shopping
as sport almost Melanie Hobson thank you
very much